you grew up in new york right no no no i
grew up in plainfield illinois little
farm town on a like a corn and soybean
farm were you the type of kid that would
say to people i'm going to be famous one
day i'm going to be a comedian because
when you're when you're in a corn field
you're going to go to hollywood nobody
believes it right first of all no one's
there we had no neighbors so i'm just it
was a just a weird kid like in a barn
talking to herself i mean really yeah
and did you have fantasies of being
famous and being an actress no uh
no i don't think i knew that people i
don't know that i thought it was really
possible i knew i was slightly obsessed
with snl right because i would like
sneak and watch it when i wasn't
supposed to i like would stand in the
crack of a door and watch it when my
parents didn't know and i knew like i
loved what they were doing who were your
heroes on saturday like gilda radner and
lorraine newman and i mean all of them
actually because i just they all would
make they just would embarrass
themselves and they wouldn't care and it
was so cool to me that you know they
didn't care i'm jumping ahead but uh in
the new movie you have dan aykroyd right
yeah now that's got to be mind-blowing
when you get to work with a guy because
you were a saturday night live fan and
then you have dan aykroyd's standing so
and every movie he's made like
i mean
sitting in the car with him and he would
just randomly tell a story about when he
was making like blues like blues
brothers or he'd say something about a
certain sketch and you were like oh my
god he's talking about like the one i've
seen five thousand times yeah and he
doesn't realize he's probably thinking
you don't even know what he's talking
about but meanwhile you do know because
i'm trying really desperately to stop
going oh my god oh my god he's talking
about it and did you get to work with
bill murray recently or you have a movie
coming up st vincent's coming out and
which he's remarkable in and he's just
as brilliant he's amazing he's really
and he you know what was so cool i
didn't know because he's such an enigma
he's such a kind of
mystical guy which did not change upon
medium but
seeing how much he cares like he really
really is
it's not just like he can say anything
even though he can
he really was focused on the work and
like making sure like it you know just
seeing the care he put into it i was
like i just thought that was cool that
he could probably say anything that
would seem amazing but he really
he really cared about it